[Aplausos]
[Música]
la unión europea es el chivo expiatorio
perfecto cuando las cosas van bien en un
país miembro los gobiernos nacionales
sacan pecho pero cuando las cosas van
mal la culpa es de europa y ojo porque
esto se aplica tanto a los de derechas
como a los de izquierdas
[Música]
durante estos días de cuarentena y
coronavirus todos hemos oído la misma
queja como es posible que la unión
europea no haya hecho nada para ayudar
en esta crisis y la pregunta la
auténtica pregunta es y que podía hacer
lo digo en serio pensando por un momento
por ejemplo los presupuestos de sanidad
son competencia nacional y lo mismo pasa
con los sistemas sanitarios mucha gente
piensa que toda europa tiene un sistema
de salud completamente público pero no
es cierto en realidad existen dos
grandes modelos de sanidad el modelo
bismarck y el modelo beveridge el modelo
bismarck está basado en agencias de
seguros públicas y privadas por ejemplo
yo vivo en república checa en praga yo
tengo que elegir una compañía de seguros
el precio está regulado por el estado
eso sí pero si mañana yo tengo un
problema puedo elegir un hospital
privado y mi seguro cubre todo el
tratamiento o al menos una parte eso es
el sistema bismarck sin embargo si
viviera en españa el estado cubriría
todo el tratamiento y no podría elegir
hospitales
[Música]
esto es porque en españa al igual que en
otros países tienen un modelo beveridge
que está basado en el modelo británico y
lo mismo pasa con el presupuesto de
sanidad por ejemplo en alemania tienen
24 camas de cuidados intensivos por cada
100.000 habitantes en españa son 9,7
camas y en finlandia 6,1 pero no sólo
eso a ver cuáles son las principales
medidas para luchar contra el sars
coronavirus 2 seguro que todos ya sois
expertos en todas y cada una de ellas
porque las estamos viendo en directo
cuarentenas confinamientos corrieron a
la policía cerrar fronteras pues bien
todo esto son políticas nacionales es
más donde si tiene un papel europa es en
las recomendaciones y ya podéis ver el
caso ya hace en algunos países miembros
como por ejemplo españa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
marchas del 8 ms celebraron en contra
del criterio de la agencia europea
sin embargo hay una cosa en la que la
unión europea así puede ayudar y eso es
la economía y no creáis que es poca cosa
veréis nadie sabe cómo será el mundo
tras la crisis del coronavirus pero hay
una cosa que está muy clara vamos a
sufrir una recesión de proporciones
nacho vidal ianas hemos paralizado todo
nuestro tejido productivo por varias
semanas muchas empresas que ya estaban
entre la espada y la pared van a tener
que echar el cierre y eso significa
miles de trabajadores en el paro siento
decíroslo pero nos espera un año muy
pero que muy malo y no solo en españa o
en europa sino en prácticamente todo el
mundo
coronavirus un número récord americano
se registra como desempleado y como os
podéis imaginar los gobiernos van a
tener que sacar planes de ayuda líneas
de crédito para empresas exenciones de
impuestos o directamente subvenciones
algunos países como por ejemplo
república checa- ya han anunciado que
durante unos meses los autónomos no van
a tener que pagar la seguridad social
por cierto que ya podrían tomar nota los
políticos españoles verdad en conclusión
la factura del coronavirus va a ser muy
pero que muy cara y la pregunta es cómo
se va a pagar pues muy sencillo con
deuda los gobiernos de todo el planeta
tendrán que sacar montones de bonos de
deuda al mercado y aquí en europa han
vuelto a sacar del cajón una vieja idea
los eurobonos ahora conocidos como
corona bonos en lugar de que cada país
saque sus propios bonos de deuda
europa sacaría un mega bono que
englobaría a todos los miembros de la
eurozona como os podéis imaginar españa
e italia están deseando que ocurra algo
así sin embargo no todos los países
están de acuerdo
[Música]
los alemanes y los holandeses bloquean
los corona bonos de la unión europea en
una conferencia europea y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando especialmente si veis
este vídeo desde españa esta película ya
la hemos visto esto es un nuevo capítulo
más de la historia norte de europa
contra sur de europa los países del
norte son partidarios de la austeridad y
los países del sur son partidarios de
gastar dinero como si no existiera
mañana de nuevo volvemos a la tensión
dentro de europa y creedme no hablamos
de palabras vacías sin ir más lejos el
primer ministro de portugal ha dicho ya
que la postura de holanda es repugnante
y los medios españoles ya han empezado a
cargar sus tintas contra países bajos y
alemania así que la pregunta que hoy nos
hacemos es realmente estamos hablando de
solidaridad de verdad holanda y alemania
son los malos en esta película hasta qué
punto los eurobonos o los corona bonos
son una buena solución para la corona
crisis hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
nuevos desafíos viejas recetas la crisis
financiera de 2008 se saldó con una
crisis de deuda por aquel entonces
portugal italia grecia y españa-
necesitaban pedir préstamos y si los
pongo en este orden porque la prensa
internacional llamaba estos países los
peaks no porque fueran unos cerdos sino
porque era de portugal y de italia g de
grecia y st spain pues bien los picks
necesitaban dinero y qué hace un país
cuando quiere pedir dinero prestado
[Música]
lo más normal es emitir bonos de deuda
en el mercado es decir que tú como
inversor compras un papelito que dice
que españa o el país de turno te
devolverá lo que has pagado con un
interés el problema pues que hay países
que no devuelven esas deudas y creedme
si una empresa os debe dinero tenéis un
problema pero si quieres debe dinero es
un estado ya podéis empezar a rezar
queréis un ejemplo pues os doy un
ejemplo
los inversores se preparan para tener
perdidas en las conversaciones de la
deuda argentina exacto miles de
inversores que prestaron dinero
argentina dan por hecho que han perdido
toda su inversión y los que se atreven a
reclamar lo que les deben corren el
riesgo de que les llamen fondos buitres
terroristas financieros y muchas otras
lindezas
en este caso diríamos que argentina
tiene un alto riesgo de impago y qué
pasa cuando un país tiene un alto riesgo
de impago pues que tiene que pagar más
intereses por la deuda
[Música]
en otras palabras yo no me fío de que tú
me vas a devolver lo que te he prestado
pero si me prometes que me vas a
devolver mucho más de lo que te he
dejado a lo mejor me planteo correr el
riesgo eso explica que el bono de deuda
argentina a 10 años tengo un interés del
30 por ciento mientras que el de
alemania tenga atentos un -0 37 por
ciento y si habéis oído bien si prestáis
dinero alemania en estos momentos no
sólo no os dan interés sino que tenéis
que pagarles vosotros y todo esto por
qué pues porque todo el mundo decía de
que alemania devolverá sus deudas y
diréis y cómo se mide el riesgo de un
país es más quien mide el riesgo de
impago pues el riesgo de impago lo miden
empresas especializadas las llamadas
agencias de calificaciones
principalmente hay 3
moody's fitch y standard and poor's
estas agencias estudian los libros de
cuentas de un país su estructura
económica las empresas y ven cómo de
posible es que devuelvan las deudas pues
bien tras la crisis de 2008 países como
españa tenían déficits enormes eso
significa que el gobierno estaba
gastando mucho más de lo que ingresaba
en impuestos a esto hay que sumarle el
paro problemas estructurales y
corrupción
[Música]
en otras palabras españa tenía un riesgo
de impago muy alto y esto qué significa
pues unos intereses de la deuda
altísimos para que os hagáis una idea en
españa todavía hoy en día los intereses
de la deuda son la tercera partida más
grande de los presupuestos del estado en
otras palabras que si no eres alemania
países bajos finlandia a un país muy muy
muy solvente pedir dinero prestado puede
salirte muy pero que muy caro pero
esperad un momento porque hay otra
alternativa si si en lugar de sacar
bonos de deuda al mercado podemos
pedirle prestado
a un amigo en este caso el amigo es la
unión europea sí amigos de visual
política hablamos del temido rescate
financiero
un rescate financiero es básicamente un
préstamo con intereses muy bajos y
diréis y dónde está la trampa porque
decimos que es tan temido pues porque si
el coste económico es muy bajo pero el
coste político es altísimo básicamente y
cuando la unióneuropea te rescata dice
vale yo te dejo el dinero pero voy a
controlar lo que haces con él porque no
me fío un pelo de ti y creedme en
aquellos años
europa tenía muchas razones para no
fiarse de los picks y hombre aquí creo
que nadie me puede acusar a mí de tener
ningún prejuicio contra españa más que
nada porque soy español pero es que hay
cosas que es que si se las cuentas un
cura le crece la sotana por ejemplo
mientras españa estaba pasando por su
peor crisis económica madrid se
presentaba como candidata a celebrar los
juegos olímpicos eso por no hablar de
todos los casos de corrupción empresas
con privilegios y un largo etcétera en
otras palabras que lo último que querían
los políticos españoles tanto los de
izquierdas como los de derechas es que
llegaran unos señores de bruselas a
revisar nuestras cuentas por estos años
es cuando se acuñó la expresión los
hombres de negro
[Música]
los hombres de negro eran esos malvados
burócratas europeos que venían a decirle
a los pobres políticos españoles lo que
tenían que hacer y entonces es cuando la
comisión europea apoyada por españa e
italia sacó la idea del siglo vamos la
idea acá
en europea propone eurobonos como un
arma contra la crisis en otras palabras
los inversores no querían prestar a los
pits porque no se fiaban de ellos pero
si querían prestar a alemania ya los
países solventes los eurobonos serían un
bono que combinaría a la deuda de países
solventes con deuda de países no
solventes es decir era una forma de
esconder deuda maldad y deuda buena en
un mismo paquete pensando por un momento
si eres un país insolvente en los
eurobonos son lo mejor de ambos mundos
apenas pagas intereses económicos y
apenas tienen coste político todos son
ventajas el problema pues el problema es
que los eurobonos son el mismo mecanismo
que llevó a la crisis de 2008
es decir esa idea de esconder deuda
buena con deuda mala en un mismo paquete
a ver si cuela y los inversores te lo
compran es lo mismo que hicieron los
bancos en los años 2000 que eso es lo
mismo que generó la crisis financiera
pero no sólo eso imagínate un inversor
compra un eurobono y resulta vamos a
poner que muchos países europeos no
quieren o no pueden devolver esa deuda
quien terminaría pagando por todos
exacto los países más solventes todo
esto explica que cuando bruselas propuso
estos los eurobonos alemania países
bajos y finlandia dijeron
eurobonos eurobonos del cólera que nos
la quiere colar y se cree que somos
idiotas anda mirad toma un sugus y anda
por ahí a [ __ ] a la vía vale sin
embargo la situación ha cambiado estamos
en plena crisis de coronavirus y el
fantasma de los eurobonos vuelve a sonar
en bruselas que ha cambiado ahora pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
salvar la economía o salvar tu gobierno
el coronavirus se parece a la crisis de
2008 en una cosa ha golpeado a todos los
países del mundo eso es cierto pero
también es cierto que cada uno ha
reaccionado de formas muy distintas en
el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo
alemania tiene 57 mil infectados y 422
muertos españa sin embargo 73 mil casos
y casi 6 mil muertos
luxemburgo tiene la cifra más alta de
infectados per cápita y sin embargo no
sólo no tienen los hospitales colapsados
sino que ya están aceptando enfermos del
norte de francia
[Música]
y no no es una cuestión de ser más o
menos rico por ejemplo república checa o
polonia son más pobres que españa o
italia y sin embargo están enfrentando
esta crisis con apenas muertos por
supuesto no sabemos lo que puede pasar
en unos días pero a día de hoy parece
razonable pensar que españa voluntaria
están haciendo algo mal muy mal pero de
eso ya hablamos hace un par de días en
visual política y no vamos a repetirlo
lo cierto es que al igual que la crisis
de 2008 la crisis del coronavirus se va
a saldar con enormes cantidades de deuda
cae el producto interior bruto cae la
recaudación fiscal y sube el gasto
público todos los estados de europa van
a tener que emitir deuda y aquí en este
momento es donde entra bruselas al
rescate
[Música]
el banco central europeo anunció un
programa de compras de 750 mil millones
de euros para la emergencia de la
pandemia y de nuevo hablamos de un
rescate con intereses económicos bajos
pero un coste político muy alto
[Música]
y aquí es donde entramos en la parte más
ideológica de esta historia porque
veréis tanto españa como italia han
disparado su gasto público en los
últimos años en el caso de españa el
gobierno es una coalición de socialistas
con podemos ponemos para que no lo sepa
es un partido político que surge en el
año 2014 para oponerse a las condiciones
que ponía a europa cuando rescató españa
es decir que si estaban en contra de los
'hombres de negro' es muy difícil pensar
que vayan a recibirles con los brazos
abiertos ahora mismo en otras palabras
que el presidente del gobierno español
pedro sánchez se puede enfrentar a un
dilema muy difícil
[Música]
[Aplausos]
con cambio de socios de gobierno o
convocan nuevas elecciones lo primero
sería muy difícil lo segundo sería
arriesgarse a perder el gobierno y algo
parecido pasa en italia en este caso
tenemos un gobierno del movimiento cinco
estrellas el movimiento cinco estrellas
es otro partido político que surgió ex
profeso para oponerse a las condiciones
que imponía europa con rescato italia es
decir que estaban en contra de los
hombres de negro y es muy difícil
imaginar les recibiéndoles con los
brazos abiertos ahora mismo
dicho de otra forma que lo más probable
es que tanto españa' comunitaria
tuvieran que convocar nuevas elecciones
y claro visto cubo han gestionado la
crisis de coronavirus es muy fácil que
ambos gobiernos perdieran las elecciones
así que la única solución políticamente
viable que les queda es esta
en los corona bonos podrían rescatar y
unir a toda europa en otras palabras que
tanto el gobierno de españa como el de
italia no quieren tener que rendir
cuentas a europa quieren ayuda sin
compromisos de ningún tipo y así es como
llegamos a esa tensa videoconferencia
europea en el periódico el país hay una
transcripción de algunos de los momentos
más duros ahí podemos ver como españa
proponía los corona bonos como la única
solución y merkel en un tono muy
conciliador decía lo siguiente
[Aplausos]
el mecanismo de rescate es un
instrumento muy bueno al final sé que te
va a ayudar no seas tan crítico si lo
que estás esperando son los corona bonos
no van a llegar nunca mi parlamento no
lo aceptaría estáis generando
expectativas que no se van a cumplir y
lanzando mensajes de división
angela merkel cancillera alemana
[Música]
por supuesto que hay dos formas de ver
esta discusión a prensa española ya lo
está empezando a vender como el norte de
europa que no quiere ayudar al sur sin
embargo hay otra forma de verlo
podríamos decir que tanto españa como
italia no quieren verse obligados a
tener que convocar nuevas elecciones y
están dispuestos a lo que sea para
evitarlo así que ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros creéis que españa e italia
deberían aceptar la ayuda de europa
aunque eso signifique que tengan que
hacer nuevas elecciones es más
importante salvar objetivos económicos o
salvar objetivos políticos
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios por cierto que si os
interesa podéis echar un vistazo a este
otro vídeo donde se explica muy bien lo
que se está haciendo en la unión europea
para luchar contra el coronavirus alemán
ya envió un millón de mascarillas a
italia francia hizo lo mismo y además
añadió 20.000 trajes de protección
austria por su parte donó 16 millones de
mascarillas a italia y es un vídeo del
canal de mi amigo karim halal que ya ha
salido alguna vez por aquí seguramente
algunos le conozcáis y de verdad que
merece mucho la pena porque está muy
bien documentado y como siempre no
olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribir
al político y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo darle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]